[Music]
with the Batman Warner Brothers managed
to release a big hit in 2022 wowing both
viewers and critics Robert patson in
particular was impressive in the lead
role as The Dark Knight therefore
everyone is eagerly awaiting the
announced sequel the Batman part two
well there is already some information
about the sequel so it's high time to
have a closer look at the
project despite the change of management
of DC and the entire reorientation in
the film and series business the plans
for the Batman 2 have not been altered
although this Batman will not be part of
the new DCU he will belong to the
so-called elseworlds these are alternate
stories that have no impact in the
events of the DCU for example The Joker
movies with waen Phoenix also belong to
the group of elseworlds so we can expect
that the creators will be able to fully
dedicate themselves to the continuation
of their idea from the prequel without
having to worry about the other movies
in the
franchise when it comes to the familiar
cast of the Batman 2 there are few
surprises to begin with of course Robert
patson returns as Bruce Wayne many fans
and critics were skeptical before part
one as to whether the former Twilight
star could live up to the demands of a
Batman however he eventually won
everyone over Batman's Ally in the
police James Gordon will again be played
by Jeffrey Wright and Andy Circus will
also be seen again as Butler Alfred
pennyworth many would like to see Zoe
Kravitz return as Catwoman but there's
still no word on whether she'll be
reprising her role the bad guy remains
an exciting subject The Joker made his
first appearance in the finale of the
first part where he was portrayed by
Barry kogan afterwards a five scene was
released in which the Joker and Batman
had a conversation whether he will
finally get his big appearance in the
second part remains unknown though
director and screenwriter Matt Reeves
keeps emphasizing that he doesn't want
to make the same mistakes like those in
other Batman movies where the villain is
more important than the main character
Bruce Wayne is to stay at the core of
the story so it might still be too early
for a colorful character like the Joker
instead a different major character
could come into Batman's life Matt
Reeves has long had the wish to
reintegrate Robin into the Batman
Universe the director has already stated
this in the past if Robin were to play a
role his story would also be very
emotional which villain we can expect in
the Batman 2 and whether Robin will be
involved naturally depends on the Story
part one was based in the comics year
one ego and the long Halloween whether
there are plans to build the sequel on
specific comic strips is sadly still
unknown as you can tell from the style
of the first film Matt Reeves is trying
to make the Dark Knight and his
antagonists seem much more realistic
unlike in the DCU for example at the
same time he's also a self- professor
fan of offbeat villains in an interview
with collider he once commented in my
view I just feel drawn to finding the
grounded version of everything so to me
it would be a challenge in an
interesting way to try and figure out
how that could happen even the idea of
something like Mr Freeze that is such a
great story right I think there's
actually a grounded version of that
story which could be really powerful and
could be really great there are still a
lot of questions regarding the exact
plot Robert patom himself would like the
court of owls or the calendar man as the
bad guys the court would actually not be
that unlikely it's a secret society that
controls Gotham From The Underground
very fitting for the crime and Thriller
feel of the prequel film calender man
would be pretty similar to The Riddler
instead of riddles he uses special
holidays or other important dates as the
foundation for his crimes in March
rumors started circulating that the new
villain would be Clayface this is a DC
villain who appears in two versions in
the comics version one Matthew Hagen is
a treasure hunter who gains the ability
to manipulate his fysical features after
being exposed to a radioactive pool
version two basil as Carlo is an actor
who once played a villain named Clayface
and now seeks revenge on those involved
in a Movie remake however the rumors
came to nothing to this day there is no
official statement as to which
antagonist or antagonists we can
actually expect of course the Joker is
still an option after all he is the only
one who was already teased in the first
film like the first movie Matt Reeves is
in charge of directing and writing the
screenplay however he is not alone in
writing the script and is actively
supported by Peter Craig and Mattson
Tomlin both of whom also contributed to
the first part sadly the start of
shooting has been postponed due to the
writers and actor strike in Hollywood
originally it was supposed to kick off
on November 23rd 2023 but now March 2024
has been targeted so we will probably
see the first trailer at the end of next
year at the earliest the actual movie is
then still a long time coming the
current date for the theatrical release
of the Batman 2 is October 3rd 2025 if
you cannot wait until then you can at
least look forward to the Penguin series
with Colin frell the series produced by
HBO is skipped for release as early as
next year and will of course be set in
the same Gotham as the
Batman well that's the current status of
the Batman 2 which bad guy would be your
favorite and who should play him can
Things become a bit more crazy or should
Matt Reeves stick to his principles and
focus more on down toe villains we are
looking forward to your thoughts in the
[Music]
comments